now I I was in a bit of a I was in a bit
of an exploratory mood on the internet
just yesterday which I want to do and
usually that leads me to town roads of
bizarre versions of porn but last night
I went down a road where I was looking
into computer learning machine learning
neural network simulation stuff like
that yada yada yada ya ski blabbity flee
but it blow buddy blow and what i found
was this cool game that kind of
simulates the idea of this nonsense here
i found this game and it's called
evolution what you do in this game is
you kind of build your own version of a
creature and you give it muscles and
bones and joints and basically you just
kind of see what it can do and you can
judge by how many how many of the
population you want like how how
complicated your neural network is gonna
be I don't know I don't even know but in
the at the end of the day you've got
this creature that has the ability this
creature is not gonna go anywhere is it
huh
yeah whatever we'll see what happens so
you just got this creature and then it
randomly determines like what it's cold
god that one's doing good going the
wrong way oh look at him look at him go
see and so it takes the best of the last
generation and then it kind of is like
yeah that one wasn't so [ __ ] oh god why
no that's that can't be the winner oh no
that is the winner and then it takes the
winner from the last one and it's like
no this is what we're gonna do god
dammit well that's not walking that's
flopping on your ass so yeah this is the
game so you generally just kind of go
through it waiting for these guys to
eventually get better and better and
with each generation we're on the fifth
generation now you kind of just like
it's there we go that's a winner right
there see the other one was just no
progress to be had but this one's
actually walking no that's the wrong way
you idiot god damn it this stupid pieces
yeah it's it's like you're just watching
your children go flop around in the yard
for a few hours and like hopefully one
of them actually learns to walk and then
the strongest survives and you you
that to breed more the the children
analogy was not correct on this one the
lag this is awful what a [ __ ] lag I
my streams doing great ain't nothing
wrong with my look I'm simulating life
here this is life and there's no lag it
when it comes down to life look at these
bad boys see more and more of my
precious spawn more and more of my
precious precious children are finding
their way through the world trying to
get better and better look at that over
a cheat oh well you got some competition
oh my god you are so goddamn good and
see look at flappy over there and
eventually you'll get something that
kind of looks a little bit like walking
because the only objective is to go
farther right so it's it's like it
determines what its gonna do based on
how far it can go now the only
complicated thing is I didn't exactly
give it a lot to work with I think there
might be a limit here because I don't
know how it can make locomotion with
just this simple joint thing going on -
see it's not it's got no traction on
there so they're trying to do something
but it ain't working so this is my fault
the the seed was bad therefore the
yielding result ain't so good either now
I'm sure there's some way to get it out
of here but this ain't uh this ain't
good I ain't too proud of dad here no no
I ain't proud daddy or you get you get
the [ __ ] out of you freaks all right so
the problem obviously was the problem
obviously was that they didn't look a
thing like me we're gonna make me I'm
gonna make a man out of you this is not
gonna go well and then just a stick for
a head cuz I don't think you deserve to
have a full head going on there in fact
I don't know why I made so many joints
on the arms I'm just gonna delete these
no the thing I've learned playing around
with this is best to start out as simple
as possible because if you don't you're
gonna have a bad time all right
go my demon children go go my dear go go
my demon children husband stand it up
hey good job there well done for you
well done you pile
sticks oh good I love seeing the best of
generation one he's doing leg raises
where did you go oh yeah you got um yeah
you got this and then you just watch it
for a long long time until it eventually
figures out that leg raises aren't the
best thing that you can do you gotta
eventually stand your self beyond look
at that guy hey oh damn you man / look
at us man pers oh no spammer made it
this man / did good
maybe yes man / did a little good almost
something in the way of resembling
walking Oh hippity hoppity hip hop
hippity hop hop hippity hoppity come on
oh you you piece of [ __ ] this man Bert
nice man perfect whoa whoa did you see
that whoa what the hell oh they're
[ __ ] oh no no hey whoa hey this is a
family-friendly channel guys got guys
guys oh god I didn't want any of this
happen I was trying to make it so that
this would be educational educational at
best and yet it's turned into something
along the lines of this now now all I
can see when I look at this is just like
it's some big orgy going on and this is
how they keep getting batches of 50 for
the next generation so quickly is this
breakdancing I love it so it takes a
long time to work out something in the
semblance of not horrifying and not
yucky
and this is both horrifying and whew
oh my god they're starting to walk it's
starting oh man we got we got
competition up in the walking's yeah you
go you got it yeah you got it oh man
they're walking that's how they learned
out of sex standing up this is like if
babies were somehow fully grown adults
the second they shot out of the womb I
imagine all this sounds like emanating
from this pile just the
but times 50 I'm more Slurpee like just
a lot of that noise going on I am NOT a
proud papa I am not but you can see
we're in generation 24 right now and
they're starting to walk which is a bad
prospect so much but [ __ ] I don't even
know if these things have butts I don't
even know if these things have a nooses
Oh Oh God oh my god it's just like like
occasionally might my brain Oh like like
look at that it's like that's some
horrible SCP monster just something with
like a way too many hands way too many
limbs and all moving in a coordinated
like horrifying fashion like that yeah
it's pretty much how the world end just
imagine all these with a like each of
them having my face on them they take
after their papa just cloned myself a
million times there's the end result of
the horrifying cloning oh they're
beautiful
and this is the 46 generations it took
46 generations of not knowing anything
about coordinated movement not knowing
anything about trying to go from A to B
it didn't know [ __ ] about that that's
not what it knew so it just took bones
joints muscles and it basically just
threw a bunch of attempts through random
chance and the only objective is getting
farther and from that I have input
nothing I have done nothing to these I
have taught them nothing you think I
taught them that I didn't teach them
that horrifying zombie shambling walk
this is what they figured out on their
own and this is like what it's like a
what a lot of like game development AI
development stuff like that is kind of
proving is like the concept of AI
figuring [ __ ] out kind of like this
evolutionary process of like neural
thing it's not complicated it really is
not complicated it's just like trial and
error over generation after generation
millions and millions of generations
it's kind of just trial and error and so
when it comes down to games
it's like fascinating to see that things
can just be procedurally made like this
and
and adapt after that yeah it makes you
terrified for the future donut the
majority of them have figured out how to
walk but uh they're steadily steadily
getting faster the ones that fall at the
beginning they have a mutation that that
actually worked against them because
there's mutations like with random
chance and random mutations sometimes it
works against them like they fall
sometimes it works for them and they go
faster and then they got this horrible
shambling whoa well I think that's about
as good as this one's gonna get so we
got to make a new one so this is my
horrible children my parting words see
you are go away and get off my lawn I
hate you and I wish you were gone
farewell and forever go away anyway see
ya alright so let's uh let's forget
about this horrible monstrosity we can
also like put like a basic one but we
can also get obstacle oh is it like
which one gets highest when the obstacle
goes over what about climbing hailer
whoa I forgot I built this one oh yeah
why did I call this one idea you know
every I remember there was a problem
here a structural integrity was a bit of
an issue also I remembered this this is
a problem right here it's chica it's
chicken how are you good girl oh god I
forgot to put you on the stand oh god I
forgot I made fifty of you more
complicated they are the harder they are
to um this is good ten of you I don't
think you're gonna be good at climbing
up the stairwell okay nope this is sad
oh wow Wow see that's how quickly they
can learn not to fall to their do take
oh god oh no all of oh no they've lost
all progress because now they're just
falling again
oh no well that's not good I imagine
like a complicated thing like this is
gonna be a lot more challenging than say
trying to just walk forwards I don't
know how in the world they're gonna be
able to climb up these stairs I don't
know how many generations would take cuz
they've already forgotten how to hold on
for dear life but any evolution off of
that would just like cause chaos I
imagine and so yeah they're having a
rough day they're generally kind of
slowing down they're generally kind of
slowing down and I'm actually impressed
by that that tails causing issues I
don't think it's a tail the tails
actually like holding them in place if
you look at the small little indentation
there when it looks at the best one it's
actually like the ones that are most
successful or because the tail acts as
like a brace even though the tail is
weighing them down and like tossing them
backwards I think they would fall anyway
like some of them are using that tail
over their advantage maybe not I don't
think you know as much as I'm I'm a
proud papa chica I don't think chica was
cut out - maybe no I think actually
maybe the tail is causing issues let's
just make the tail a little bit higher
up she's happy like my wet or I'm a
happy puppy let's scooch her in nice but
they're cheeky
all right let's scoot your in a bit
she's got a thicker neck than that let's
put her snore fur right there we go
that's looking a bit more cheek ask
she doesn't never wear to hump in her
back there we go there we go that's that
looks like a chica
order on the dáil there all right chica
you cook climb those stairs you're gonna
kill it they're gonna get it I'm so
proud of you I'm gonna give you another
bone there give you another bone here
just for structural stability
I like being stable dad I know you do
chica I am well aware that you like
stability above all else all right let's
try it oh boy she's fast I gotta give it
to her she's and she's I'm trying to
Train chica and all of her ill-begotten
spawn she's doing her best she's trying
real hard she wants to succeed and she
will is eventually I think the problem
is she has no mechanism by which to go
higher the best that she can hope for is
just to stay Stockstill and I think
that's what the evolution of this is
just gonna do and that's her natural
response into crisis situations is to
freeze absolutely freeze in place and I
think like I think that's I think that's
true to life I think if anything is true
to life that is in fact true to life all
right let's get her who's gonna run in
the get her in an open field and running
go chica go um I think the muscles in
her face ain't doing her any it's really
her she's so frozen
[Laughter]
[Music]
go chica go go go go go go go go go this
is the definition of baby steps right
here because one of they're making very
little progress but they're making
progress I think I think the problem is
what I got to do I think I got to make
like a muscle that bridges the gap here
because and that's not normal I know I
know it's not normal and let me make a
counterbalance tale a little longer
she's happier or she's about to shoot
poop out of her butthole there we go now
we've got something now we've got
something now we're getting somewhere
now we've oh wow that was pretty
impressive I've had I've had one where
oh god its evolution is like based on a
glitch and I think this is gonna be one
of those things where it's like it's for
burgers and just because it glitched out
super-hard yeah oh it's gonna be one of
the sheikah no don't tap into the dark
under all the power chica don't do it
chica no oh god she's doing it she's
tapping into her unknown powers from a
dimension beyond dollars there's no way
that will ever survive the repercussions
or whatever this is leading towards it's
dark cheek well good job girl wait Oh
way to go you know eventually this is
gonna turn out to be like really
impressive but at the moment it's quite
perturbing I got it marked chicas in the
upset yeah something like that
Oh same as ever
yes one went way high oh there she good
thing that's the winning generation just
ball good girl she's such a good girl
she our face she's such a good girl look
at her go
oh she's really fighting there she go oh
she's trying to learn how to do a
backflip I think I think that's her
objective here is basically the game but
I don't think cheek is gonna get very
far so what I want to do what I want to
do is I want to get a creature that's
actually gonna go far and I think like
the best ones are spider based they're
like these horrible well spiders it just
looks like one big spider hang on I
gotta go back I gotta make a bigger
bigger generation pool for more I'm
gonna go back to ten I was gonna keep it
to ten eventually we're gonna get to
Spider Man here but you know we got
evolutions baby steps you gotta yeah to
make it as far as you can see what's
weird is like it looks the when this is
happening it looks natural eventually
even the failures kind of look natural
it's just it's bizarre in the way that
yes it kinda is natural because this
it's just trying to move based in a
world of physics and as a limited world
of physics but yeah it's trying to move
and it's working why is it working
arachnophobia intensifies yeah kinda
it's like a bunch of baby spiders just
shooting out of the baby spider womb
because spiders give live birth I think
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure they go
into labor and then they shoot out and
then they just do this for a little bit
until they can figure out how to
they lay eggs I don't think that's right
I don't think that's right at all
I don't think spiders lay eggs that
doesn't make any sense at all I'm pretty
sure when a daddy spider a daddy spider
loves a mommy spider the daddy spiders
penis will get erect and then he will
insert it into the mommy spiders vagina
and then nine months later it comes out
a bunch about a thousand spider babies
like a shotgun like a like that right at
your face just like the spider mom when
she's about to give birth she goes seeks
out the nearest face because spider moms
can recognize that when they're about to
give birth and then they just like aim
and then you've got thousands of these
little things trying to eat your entire
face so to recap daddy spider wink wink
wink wink wink II loves mommy spider
daddy spider penis erect and then into
mommy spider ah and then spiders give
birth like a shotgun blast into the
nearest face I'm pretty sure that's
correct no I don't even bother looking
it up because that is exactly what
happens I am a hundred percent positive
about that you don't even need to ask
your teachers when you see them next
they will confirm this is how spiders
reproduce then what's the eggs hanging
from your basement ceiling you have no
idea I don't know what they could be and
in fact I'm pretty sure your parents are
hiding something from you if you've got
weird what you may think is a spider egg
hanging from your ceiling there's been
animal science 101 with Marv but this is
this got to be at least 301 or 302 at
the very minimum you got to give me that
I know my [ __ ] when it comes to animal
reproduction ask me any animal combo I
can tell you what how when and where
they reproduce and where they shoot
their babies once they shoot him out of
there whatever vagina they have ask me
anything I got this can spiders double
pump absolutely 100% platypus
platypi don't reproduce it's always the
same platypus from the beginning of
platypus time to the end of platypus
time
have you ever seen a platypus die no
think so never seen a platypus get old
no didn't think so yeah it's always the
same one cat and cow I think we can all
imagine what that looks like and anyway
I was asking more in a hypothetical
sense I don't actually want to know what
you're talking about
also why is a spider not actually doing
anything the spider seems to have fallen
into an evolutionary trap where it's not
making any progress no no it was a
hypothetical question all you perverts
that want to see a hamster [ __ ]
elephant you guys are [ __ ] weird and
disgusting you are disgusting because
that just ain't right like that's that's
not right at all number one the elephant
would kill the hamster probably straight
up and that's horrible in and of itself
but even if they succeeded like you want
to see some [ __ ] up [ __ ] and that's
not what I uh I'm not about that
where's the spore you know this kind of
like what spores about but spore they
don't actually figure out what they're
doing spore they just know what they're
doing from the get-go which i think is
boring I think in Spore they shouldn't
know what they're doing from the get-go
and they should figure it out just like
this because that's more interesting in
my opinion because what if they were
also going through their social dynamics
[ __ ] well I'll try to figure this
[ __ ] out I don't think it'll work out as
nicely mark this is horrifying well it
is spook Tober orc october depending on
what you subscribe to what do you think
would should we start a poll its poop
Tober versus [ __ ] tober cuz i've always
known as it is [ __ ] Tober well it's
pretty much seems to be pretty
overwhelming on [ __ ] Tober no no there's
some spooked overs coming in here why
what you guys don't know it is [ __ ]
Tauber I thought everyone knew it is
[ __ ] Tauber that's where the origination
of all the the mass texts came from like
oh yeah eat it's October if you want to
get those tasty eggplant emoji water
spray emoji like trick-or-treat
it's more like tricker yeet am i right
you know what I'm talking about
everybody knows that I'm tired I'm not
the weirdo here you're the weirdo for
not knowing it no you're talking about
I'm not bizarre just cuz I know this and
you don't everyone knows this
you're poor innocent mind look a
strawpoll that'll solve it okay that I
think that's the only thing that can
solve it are hang on let's see which is
it spooped Ober or October there we go
easy okay there we go I did it I got it
got it
okay what's the results that's what I
thought oh wait no that's not in my
favor I thought it was in my favor but
it is an even 60/40 split if we could
get that up to a 69 split I'd really
appreciate it guys you got to get one of
those numbers to 69 percent I don't care
which one but in this poll you have to
get it to 69 percent that's the only
thing that you have to do no that's the
wrong way you guys suck
come on get it to 69 percent you got it
I don't care which one it is get one of
those numbers to 69 or vote for spooked
Ober just cuz I guess you can't see the
numbers so I guess I'm gonna do whatever
whatever you know what I don't
understand how the internet works I
don't understand how polls work and
apparently I don't understand how [ __ ]
Tober works so the ant the result is 60%
for spooked over 40% Fork October I
guess I've lost this spider is just a
dumb piece of [ __ ] that's fallen into a
loop of stupidity and we've got nothing
okay so what I'm gonna do we're gonna do
one last thing I'm gonna I'm gonna
create magic okay all right we're gonna
zoom out because we're gonna need a lot
of space for this one everybody hold a
shot up hang on hold on I got this it's
not a penis of course it's not a penis
what's wrong with you yeah here we go
okay all right
hush hush hush you have no idea what's
happening right now yeah I gotta leave
is real quick cuz I gotta put a joint
here for the sake of what I'm about to
do which is glasses there we go
well that looks what I would call good
looks like he's looking up like yeah
definitely definitely good oh god now
I've ruined it I've ruined it I can't be
like this I got to find a way to be a
little more subtle about this there we
go alright yep that's oh boy yo homie no
yoy me no way so nicely defined cheeks
oh he's got a butt chin I figured just
for stability I have to have like these
here cuz otherwise this is gonna dangle
or maybe I want that maybe I want just a
little bit of dangle nobody said I
didn't like no dangle right okay I don't
know how this is gonna work well let's
see what happens Oh
turns out structural integrity was a bit
of an issue gonna get a little more
stable and it's gotta be a little more
stable it's gonna lose a bit of the the
beauty the beauty is gonna be gone a bit
but I think it's gonna be worth it in
the long run cuz we got a we've got to
make some sacrifices here that still
looks that still looks definitely still
looks oh yeah that that looks oh that
doesn't work at all hang it I think we
got to get some more muscle in here just
to increase the rigidity of it I like
rigidity
uh-huh this is gonna probably work yes
yeah yeah that looks nope horrible turns
up it's horrible turns out it doesn't
work and it's horrible okay I think it
needs more leg usually in my experience
when something ain't working right more
leg yeah this is gonna be the one all
right there we go that's just really
good Oh God oh good Hey look at the best
of generation one it actually looks like
what it's supposed to look like
amazingly up now don't oh that's
horrible that's not good I don't like
how that worked
oh you know what I did wrong ah man I
I've made this mistake before you can't
put because these can these can contract
and expand so you got to be careful with
putting um too many on there that's
right because I don't want them to
contract and expand too much here we go
that's worse it's worse it's gotten
worse bag of mush now okay I think also
I'm gonna remove because I don't think
these muscles inside here are doing us
any good so I'm just gonna take out all
the interior muscles cuz I think there's
just too much control of the creature of
the Larry here from the inside and I
definitely don't it didn't help no
didn't help he's buggin out oh boy Larry
ain't doing so good
okay well it's fun while it lasted all
right bye you horrible horrible horrible
thing I'm gonna call you Larry
by Larry got another idea I call him
tall man as tall as you can plainly see
he's quite tall and that is obvious but
now he needs arms very dangly arms and
[Music]
there we go that's all he needs
okay have at it oh boy oh hey Wow okay
well oh boy
one of them stood up one of them was
still standing
oh it crossed his leg like lady oh hey
and timber one of us figured out how to
stand up I'm the spreadeth incredible
spread Wow
he's trying so hard he's doing his best
he's he's doing his butt oh look it and
they're [ __ ] okay well now it's come
full circle
well that's okay all right well okay
they all right well um I thought it was
gonna be less sexual than this but it
seems like it's the only thing they know
how to do which is just depravity
all right okay that's enough of that all
right I'm done with that
[Music]